llegó el momento para la economía
france24 me acompaña nuestro compañero y
periodista especializado jorge hurtado
jorge vamos a hablar hablando de la
reserva federal porque ya conocemos la
minuta que revelaron bueno todo parece
indicar según esta minuta que la reserva
federal de eeuu va a aumentar de forma
más agresiva los tipos de interés este
año las minutas de la última reunión
apuntan a un incremento de medio punto
porcentual el resto del año según las
actas la mayoría de los directores del
banco central estadounidense indicaron
que una o varias subidas en medio punto
podrían ser apropiadas durante su último
encuentro el banco central
estadounidense subió el tipo de interés
oficial en 0,25 puntos porcentuales
luego de dos años anclado en niveles
cercanos a cero para contener los
efectos sobre la economía que dejó la
pandemia los directores se van a reunir
el 3 y el 4 de mayo para definir la
política monetaria de ese país en eeuu
el índice de precios al consumidor se
disparó en febrero hasta el 79 por
ciento interanual y es el registro más
alto de los últimos precios de consumo
en ese país desde principios de 1982
ahora que seguimos en eeuu por qué
ejecutivos del sector del petróleo
comparecieron ante el congreso que pasó
bueno los legisladores estadounidenses
acusaron a los directivos de las
petroleras de estar estafando a los
ciudadanos y éstos se defendieron los
legisladores de la subcomisión de
energía y comercio de la cámara de
representantes interrogaron a las
compañías sobre las razones por la que
los precios de la gasolina siguen siendo
elevados a pesar de que el petróleo ha
mostrado signos de ir a la baja en las
últimas semanas tras la invasión de
rusia en ucrania los precios de la
gasolina en eeuu se dispararon a niveles
históricos mientras que el petróleo tras
repuntar a casi 140 dólares el barril en
marzo ha caído un 23% y los futuros de
la gasolina sin terminar descendieron un
15% entre las empresas que testificaron
esta exxonmobil chevron bites y américa
cel debón y devon energy el presidente
ex móvil daren wood dijo que la pérdida
de petróleo ruso sería la mayor
interrupción del suministro en la
historia y agregó que la solución es
aumentar la oferta un pedido que los
países productores aún no logran
escuchemos que dijo hoy en día rusia
proporciona aproximadamente el 10 por
ciento del petróleo necesario para
satisfacer la demanda mundial y
alrededor del 30 por ciento de la
demanda de gas natural de europa una
pérdida de este volumen será mucho más
significativa que el impacto del embargo
petrolero árabe y representaría la mayor
interrupción del suministro en la
historia de nuestra industria por
desgracia no hay solución rápida a corto
plazo la respuesta es sencilla si
queremos reducir los precios tenemos que
aumentar la oferta gris
tenemos que hablar ahora de una reunión
entre eeuu y cuba en el sobre el sector
agrícola así los productores de ambos
países se reunieron en la habana en una
conferencia precisamente en un contexto
en el cual hay escasez de alimentos en
la isla en la tercera conferencia
agrícola cubana estadounidense también
se abordó el tema del embargo contra
cuba vigente desde 1962 los empresarios
aseguran que de no existir la
restricción en el intercambio agrícola
mutuo rondaría los mil millones de
dólares anuales comparados con los 250
millones de dólares actuales según datos
de la asociación nacional
departamentos estatales de agricultura
de eeuu cuba importa cerca del 70% de
los alimentos que consume y desde varios
años sufre desabastecimiento de
productos básicos como el huevo la leche
el aceite el pan la harina de trigo y el
pollo escuchamos parte de lo que se vio
en esa conferencia el diseño que hemos
previsto tiene concebido que todas las
formas de propiedad y de producción se
complementen unas con otras en función
de alcanzar el desarrollo agrario que
necesitamos tiempo para los indicadores
económicos día rojo para wall street que
perdió un 0,42 por ciento con claras
caídas en el sector tecnológico tras la
publicación de las actas de la última
reunión de la reserva federal de eeuu en
europa las acciones cayeron casi un 2%
ya que los inversores se enfrentaron a
la doble preocupación primero por la
posible subida de los tipos de interés
en eeuu y las nuevas sanciones
occidentales a rusia que avivan más los
peligros de inflación en américa latina
el índice ibovespa principal referente
de la bolsa de sao paulo
medio punto porcentual en su tercera
caída consecutiva con el mercado
brasileño de acciones jornada de nada
positiva para los mercados jorge
muchísimas gracias gracias también a
ustedes por continuar con nosotros
quédense en france 24
[Música]
i